una foto de unidad pero con un clima de
tensión que el anuncio del miércoles por
parte de uruguay de explorar un tratado
de libre comercio con china no ha
sentado bien entre algunos miembros del
mercosur el presidente de luis lacalle
pou defendió su decisión alegando a la
incertidumbre que hay en torno al tlc
con la unión europea algo que el
mercosur no ha conseguido cerrar luego
de más de dos décadas de negociaciones
el mandatario uruguayo tendió la
invitación a explorar el acuerdo con
china a todo el bloque y lo finalizada
esta etapa
hablaremos con los socios y los
invitaremos a sumarse ahí si hacer un
bloque con más potencia negociadora pero
si no el uruguay va a avanzar una de las
principales voces de rechazo llegó desde
paraguay país que este jueves entregó a
uruguay la presidencia pro-témpore de la
alianza los acuerdos que podamos hacer
de manera comercial
negociando de una manera individual
diferentes economías
tenemos que evaluar la afectación de
cada uno de los países partes a países
como paraguay les preocupa el ingreso de
importaciones chinas que ya cuentan con
precios muy competitivos pero ahora con
aranceles preferenciales además las
normas del mercosur prohíben
negociaciones comerciales individuales
como las que está planteando uruguay sin
embargo la propuesta de montevideo
recibió el apoyo de otro de los socios
plenos se trata de argentina nación
sumida en una fuerte crisis económica
analizamos juntos
porque no vemos la factibilidad juntos
con 11 países entre estados miembros y
asociados y 300 millones de habitantes
mercosur viene precisamente de reforzar
su alianza con hacia el bloque acaba de
conseguir un acuerdo comercial con
singapur el debate llega ahora con china
principal socio comercial de américa
latina exceptuando a mexico